[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to chess
openings explained
i am nick risco one of the instructors
here at the st louis chess club i'm
filling in for caleb denby today
as he is on vacation he will be
returning
shortly to come back to teaching the
openings tonight's lecture is going to
be over the shreshnikov sicilian
one of the sharpest and heavily
theoretical
lines of the sicilian and one that the
world champion magnus carlsen
likes to play from time to time
okay so we're going to jump right into
the opening uh the first couple moves
we're kind of going to go over them
shortly or quickly rather because they
should be well known
this is a line where black plays knight
to c6
and after the trade in the center both
sides are going to have knights
developed
black trades off this flank pawn to try
and get some development
white trades off the center pawn to get
development or sorry black trees off the
pawn to get center pawns
my bad both sides develop nice to the
center
and after pawn to e5 this is one of the
characterizing moves of the shreshnikov
the e5 pawn is grabbing some space in
the center and more importantly
attacking
white's knight so here the question is
what should white
do with this knight you might see some
more beginner level players play the
knight back to f3
which can be playable but white can go
for something more they can go for
something
sharper more aggressive and the main
line here you will notice uh
white plays knight d to b5
and let's see the chat see if anybody
kind of has an idea of what knight to b5
is about
all sicilian lines are super theoretical
this is correct
most sicilian lines are theoretical been
heavily analyzed because the sicilian is
one of the top weapons against e4
the cubby z says knight d6 is the idea
and they are correct if black allows it
white is going to try and go knight d6
with check and then after bishop takes
d6
the queen will take on d6 and kind of
cramp black's position it's going to be
hard for black to get space in the
center
and castle
so to prevent this there's a very
important move here black has to play
in order to prevent the knight from
getting to d6 black must play pawn to d6
themselves occupy the square with the
pawn that way
if white takes they can just take back
with either the bishop
or the queen and white will lose a piece
at their pawn to d6 another very
important move for whites to play
in order to maintain control of the
center is developing the dark square
bishop
to g5 and this creates a pin on the
knight
on f6 to the queen so this knight on f6
cannot move
and the reason this is important is it
will help solidify our pawn on e4
and more importantly is control the d5
square you'll see this d5 square
becomes a very nice outpost for white's
pieces in the future
after bishop to g5 black will go ahead
and play pawn to a6 now this may seem
kind of an odd move because it's not
developing a piece it's moving upon on
the edge this is not
our classical opening principles at play
here but this knight
is kind of cramping black's position
black wants to get it out of the way
and so now white has to retreat the
knight
the only square this knight can go to is
a3
and now black will play the move pawn to
b5
after pawn to b5 black is threatening
something i'll ask the chat to see if
they can find threat
fork by maximiliano
yeah i don't know who's saying h1 but
uh for those in the chat who are saying
pawn to b4 that is the threat pawn to b4
is going to fork the knights
and because knights can't move
diagonally they cannot capture
this pawn so on this move you'll see
white play a prophylactic move they'll
develop
in the center in response to this threat
and play
knight to d5 knight to d5 is a very nice
centralizing square for the white knight
and it's adding more pressure to f6 this
pinned knight
if we can add enough pressure then
capturing on f6
may be useful for white
someone is asking about a variation
with bishop to b7 so what happens if
bishop to b7 before this variation
uh i don't know what line they're asking
about because bishop b7
isn't even possible until b5 is played
and so knight d5 is response to b5
if bishop to b7 here
let's see what happens probably a
capture on f6 to ruin the pawn structure
would be
good enough so bishop to b7
with that line being given is not the
main move here the main move here is
bishop to e7
breaking the pin and reinforcing the
knight
on f6 uh okay eric murdock says sorry
they meant
e7 with the bishop um so let's see if
the bishop goes to e7
before here so i i would assume bishop
to e7 before
b5 um here uh
not the main line but i believe most
players will play
knight to c4 and the knights will
come and develop in the center this way
possibly going to e3
looking at an outpost on d5 or f5
some other players may opt to capture on
f6
and try and target the d6 square again
but it would take a little bit of time
they would need to develop the queen and
castle queen side to give sufficient
pressure
okay back to our main line here after
bishop e7
after bishop to e7 white is going to
make a move that may look confusing to
some beginner players
and especially players who are crazy
about the bishop pair
if you never want to give up your bishop
pair for any reason
this move may look sus to you but the
move is bishop takes f6
and black normally captures with the
bishop
what is the purpose of this the purpose
of this move
is again try and reduce the pressure
in our center so this pawn on e3 does
not have a protector
after knight to d5 so once this pin is
broken the knight is threatening to
capture on e4
so bishop takes f6 bishop takes f6 our
pawn on e4
is safe black
can also try to capture with the pawn
and white can adopt kind of a fianchetto
setup after g3 and develop the bishop to
g2
and castle or develop the queen forward
and castle queen side may even be safer
because black does have this open g
file
okay bishop takes f6 and now we start
getting into the first
main um i guess deviation for white
so far this is the top move for white
the entire time but here
white kind of has two choices both
involving the c pawn
we have pawn to c3 and pawn to c4 i'm
going to ask the chat which one they
prefer
and why see which variation we can take
a look at first
why might these moves be useful
i'm annie saying yes moves c3 and c4 are
options here
does anybody know the difference between
them
we have philippe saying he wants to go
c4 amir
c4 so we'll take a look at the c4 line
first
c4 is absolutely playable by white i
believe it's the second most
popular choice in this position and the
games may continue as follows the pawn
will advance to b4 attacking the knight
on a3
the knight must move so it reroutes to
c2
and the pawn goes to a5 that way white
doesn't get away with winning a pawn
here
to develop the light square bishop white
will fianchetto because
you don't want the bishop coming staring
at your own pawns you don't want to go
to d3 where it's staring at nothing
you want to try and get it to g2 and see
if you can create life for this bishop
in the future
black castle's king side white goes
bishop to g2 the plan stated earlier
and black will go bishop to g5 now that
black has secured their king
they have this move to go bishop g5 and
prevent
the knight from trading itself for the
bishop it's not the end of the world if
white gets this trade but black would
rather retain the bishop pair it's one
of the
i guess one of the nice features of the
position for black is their bishop pair
here white castles king side the knight
goes to e7
and this is kind of a dual purpose move
one you want to get white's knight
off of this nice centralized outpost the
other reason why the knight would go to
e7 is to help prepare this
f5 push this f5 push is going to be a
resource for black to try and generate
activity in the position
that way black isn't just shuffling
their pieces mindlessly
and passively knight seed
e3 and the idea is if the black knight
captures on d5
then white's knight can recapture and
maintain a strong knight in the center
because black is trying to avoid a
knight on d5 black will sometimes take
on e3
and it would be better for the knight to
recapture you don't want to have to
recapture with your f-pawn
while it's true this opens up a file for
your rook these pawns are going to be a
long-term weakness
and this e4 pawn is not helping the life
of your bishop
so after bishop takes e3 you'll see the
knight take e3
and the knight can always come back to
d5 in the future
and then the last couple moves that are
common is bishop to e6
putting pressure on the c4 pawn it's
already protected
so queen to d3 just over protects that
way this knight can maneuver
in the future if you so please queen dc7
to add more
pressure and rook a to c1 to secure this
pawn
and this position has been theorized as
a
equal position um and we'll look at the
c3 lines but one of the main reasons why
the c4 line has been i guess less played
is because of this problem with the
pawns on the light squares
and white's bishop on the light squares
this can lead to some
pretty rough bishop end games for white
so if you do play c4 as white that is
something you're going to be mindful of
the main move we'll go back to our main
line the main move is pawn to c3
and part of this is to kind of prevent
black from pushing on the queen
side and more importantly creating this
reroute square
for the knight that we saw in the c4
line
here black can choose between castles or
bishop g5
those are the two most played moves and
they just transpose into one another
black can choose the order they play
them in black will castle
and white will play knight c2 against
both responses
and now the bishop will come to g5 here
in this line
and i'm just going to take a minute to
pause here let people kind of
soak up the position try and see if they
can find the ideas for both sides
and take a guess at what two moves are
playable here
we have the main line and there's a very
fun sideline
that we're going to get into if we have
enough time
we'll see if chat has any
recommendations
luke pitts says pawn to a4 which
is the main line we'll see if anybody's
able to find the sideline
if they know it exists h4
we have people suggesting king b4 which
would be a feat for white to play
unfortunately
it's uh not doable queen h5 or resigns
queen h5
is not the move great wolf says let's
push harry i like it so there are two
moves here
again the main line is pawn to a4 and
this very fun
sideline is pawn to h4 so we'll actually
work our way through the sideline first
because we do have a lot of meat
to chew through with the a4 lines but
pawn to h4 and there's a little trap
here if the bishop takes h4
uh white is winning on the spot we're
going to give you guys a little time to
see if you can find it
i think i saw it whiz by in chat but
disappeared before i could read it
but after what seems to be a free pawn
black is
already losing we have
sugar bear requesting knight to e3
which knight is the uh the question i'm
going to ask to sugabear
we have music guitar and james berbano
saying
queen to h5 and this is correct queen to
h5
is a winning move for white and the
reason is um
you now have two attackers on this
bishop you have the rook and the queen
it's only defended by black's queen so
if black doesn't do anything about it
then they're going to lose a bishop and
if they move the bishop back then it's
matin one
so here in this position black is
already struggling after queen h5 they
can try bishop f2
king takes f2 they're still down a piece
and now h6 to stop the mate but here
when white is up a piece
and has development on the table this is
going to be a very
fun position for white
so bishop to h4 or takes h4
is obviously not the main line
surprisingly it has been played a lot in
the lead chess database by
amateurs but as far as the master
database goes
masters are pretty smart i don't think
they're going to be taken on h4
the main move here is going to be bishop
to h6 we do have someone asking what if
they played
g5 in this attack which is a very good
question
if g5 is played simply pawn to g3 and
the bishop is trapped
okay back to the main line bishop h6 is
the main line here
and now pawn to g4 white is just going
to be really aggressive and try and push
to attack this bishop and here there is
really only one good move
for black very often you will see
black played g6 and this just cannot be
the correct approach
after pawn to g6 the dark squares are
being weakened
and white has these two pawns ready to
go and crack up black's defense
so after a move like pawn to g5
bishop to g7 here after queen to d2
you're developing the queen ready to go
you're getting ready to push h5 you can
even just go
knight c to e3 and bring in more pieces
see if you can get it onto g4 maybe sink
it in on h6 or f6
so all of white's pieces are going to be
flooding into black's position
so g6 is just too passive black needs to
make sure they're being active
and i'm seeing this move pop up in the
chat over and over everyone's suggesting
bishop to f4
and this is the main move in the
position
here queen to f3 and black is actually
going to be looking to sacrifice a pawn
here
they are going to consider allowing
white to take twice on f4
so here bishop to e6 developing and this
is the point of the pawn sack you're
sacking the pawn that way you can
develop the rest of your pieces
and here knight takes f4
pawn takes f4 and queen takes f4
you'll see the knight come to e5 kind of
stop the queen from putting pressure on
d6
because if you know white gets the
chance to castle queen side the rook is
going to end up on d1
and d6 is a target so knight to e5 just
kind of to
disrupt this influence of the queen on
the position and this is a relatively
equal
equal position here
all right let's go back losing my place
in the study
so that covers most of the h4 lines
um i think there's one variation of the
h4 lines that i'm missing out on
but i'm going to move on to the a4 lines
because like i said we do have a lot of
lines
uh in the a4 variation to cover
pawn to a4 is the main line the
shashnikov sicilian
and most theoretical positions arise
after pawn to a4
and the first move you'll see black play
in response is b
takes a4 this again also breaks some of
the classical positional rules
so here you're taking a pawn and you're
capturing towards the outside of the
board which is not
um how you're raised uh classically
with classical principles your pawns
typically want to capture towards the
center so my question is why
why doesn't black just allow white to
take so why not like
play bishop to b7 and allow white to
take this pawn here
what would the issue be
let's say bishop b7 and allow white to
take
amir notices that this line loses a pawn
amir can you give the full line please
ethan liang is saying that one reason is
it's an isolated pawn and two you're
just losing a pawn
so yeah everyone is seeing that it is
hanging upon if
they allow white to take pawn takes pawn
takes
rook takes excuse me rip takes a8
and let's say bishop takes a8 then
bishop can take
on b5 this is a plus
one position for white because they are
up a pawn
and um i think it was uh i think last
name was liang they were saying that uh
even if like this bishop weren't able to
take on b5
this pawn would be an isolated pawn on
the b file that would be a great
target for white in the future so this
is why
you will see black capture towards the
edge black doesn't want to lose this
pawn
so they have to trade it off on the a4
square
and white will recapture with the rook
it's a little odd to see the rook
just capture moving forward like this so
early before the king is even castled
but it's going to be pretty rare for
white to castle in some of these lines
black will play pond a5 to secure the
pawn
now you have three pieces protecting the
a pawn instead of just the rook
and the bishop and white will start
developing some of their other
pieces starting with bishop to c4
here we see rook to b8 putting pressure
on white's b-pawn so white plays b3 to
secure it
the bishop will protect from in front
and here we will see black
play king to h8 and again i'm going to
ask the chat what is black's plan with
king to h8 it seems a little bit of a
weird move
as it's not really developing anything
black still has this light square bishop
to develop they still have a queen that
they might want to try and get off the
back row soon
this rook on f8 is not on an open file
yet
chi is suggesting g6 and f5
imani lp is saying it's stepping out of
the night checks
music guitar saying prophylaxis so it's
kind of a mix of all of these
the knight checks is not the biggest
thing in the world both of these squares
are covered multiple times by black's
pieces by the bishop the queen the
knight the pawn
those squares are definitely covered
it's actually more about
discoveries in the future black does
want to try and play
f5 they actually don't need to play g6
first
they can play f5 right away because the
bishop on c8 is protecting the f5 square
however after pawn to f5 say like they
play pawn to f5 here
it can run into some discoveries such as
knight to e7
after knight to e7 king h8 and then
knight takes c6 white is going to be up
a piece
with a fork they're going to go up in
exchange eventually being up
a rook so king to h8
is prophylaxis um to help black play
this f5 idea
next we will see white play knight c to
e3
this does a couple things one it is
supporting the knight on d5 in case
black
plays any knight to e7 maneuver and it's
also protecting the f5
square so it kind of deters black from
playing f5 in this position
now we will see the idea of pawn to g6
to help this f5 push
pawn to g6 theoretically can also be
considered an
inaccuracy due to this upcoming
sacrifice that i will show but first
we're going to show the other line
besides g6
the other line here is bishop to e6 just
again
cutting off anything with this f pawn
this open diagonal
trying to put pressure on this d5 knight
maybe trade it off
the downside to that would be that uh
after the knight recaptures white still
has a good knight
actually sorry the move isn't bishop to
e6 i misread my notation the move is
bishop takes e3
and then knight takes e3 so again the f
pawn doesn't take
these pawns would be a little ugly for
white in any sort of end game
so the knight recaptures knight to e7
now
prepping f5 white castles
pawn to f5 trades on f5
and now we see rook to a2 this rook is
going to eventually
swing over to d2 to pressure this weak
d6 pawn
so we'll see bishop to e4 rook to d2
rook to b6 to defend rook to e1
just getting the rook onto a semi-open
file
queen to b8 and queen to a1 this
position
is known to be slightly better for white
so back to our main line g6 again
theoretically can be considered an
inaccuracy
but is probably black's best try
here white has this move pawn to h4
again we see this pawn to h4 sacrifice
now here
um after bishop takes we no longer have
queen h5
after queen h5 black is simply winning
after taking the queen
uh someone's suggesting g6 h4 bishop
h4 and then g3 can be rough so this is
actually the line that i'm going to be
covering tonight
is uh after bishop takes h4 the pawn
comes to g3
and this right here this sequence of
moves is a battle for tempo
white is trying to make sure they can
open lines for their pieces to flow
freely into the black position
and black is just trying to get greedy
and take the material so if they can
survive the attack
they may have a more fortunate endgame
so after g3 bishop goes to g5
the bishop could go to f6
but this also allows white to kind of
just get their hand at attacking
rook to a2 f4 is going to be the idea
with swinging
the a rook over to h2
yeah memento mori is saying epic rook
swing incoming this is going to be a big
idea in the shreshnikov for white
this huge rick swing how many other
openings do you get to take a rook on
the a file and move it all the way to
the h file
i can't think of any others off the top
of my head you'll see the bishop drop
back to g7
not really wanting white to take and
then sink their other knight in on d5
it might be a good piece trade for white
pawn goes to f4 again we're seeing the
path
clear open for the for the rook and
if black takes white can take back and
more lines are opening
rook to e8 will put pressure on the
e-pawn white's going to ignore it and
continue the attack on the h-file h6
is probably the only way to stop this
attack currently
and after a queen to f3 protecting the
e4 pawn
king to g8 stepping out of fire of these
rooks
and queen to g2 this position has been
known
to be much better for white stockfish 12
right now is giving this an evaluation
of
plus 2.1
so that is why you'll see the bishop
come back to g5
getting ready to trade itself for the e3
knight if necessary
pawn to f4 again battle of tempo this f4
pawn is hitting the bishop so black has
to respond to this
e takes g takes attacking the bishop yet
again
the bishop cannot take this pawn
because the knight will take i'm annie's
making the joke that uh
this opening is like theory until a draw
occurs and yes some of these lines
are worked out to draws we actually will
show one
in just a few minutes here but
uh after the pawn takes back on f4
this bishop needs to find a home and
it's going to check
on h4 and white has a decision to make
here white has already declared they're
not going to castle this rook is just
too involved in an
attack and this rook has already moved
this king is going to be hanging out in
the middle of the board
but now the question is going to be
where does white
move their king i'm going to leave this
question open to the chat and see what
ideas they have
we don't want to block the second rank
says momento mori
amir is recommending king to f1
i manny is coming in again saying king
d2 looks safer
but king f1 still allows the rook swing
more people are suggesting king to d2
just because it looks
safer so
good arguments for both sides
all right people are still split on king
d2 or king f2
some people are suggesting king e2 if
you get the chance
king e2 uh i i haven't looked into king
e2
um the old main line used to be king to
d2 the newer main line is king to f1
so first we'll look at the old line and
see why
why they switched to king f1 so king to
d2
we had a lot of people saying that king
to d2 the king looks much
safer i would have to agree just
aesthetically this looks much safer for
the white
king the drawback is it does slow down
this rook swing
you know the rook wants to go to a2 and
swing over so if you're going to play
king to d2
you're going to want to think about a
king to c1 and this is another tempo
you're going to have to spend
so we'll we'll go through the rest of
the old king d2 line
knight e7 has been played followed by
queen to g1
knight takes d5 knight takes d5 bishop
to e6
queen to h2 pawn to g5 to protect the
bishop
and here white can just take on g5
and the position gets very sharp very
quickly black will capture on g5
checking the king the king has to move
it goes to c2
pawn to h6 again just stopping any kind
of mating ideas
supporting the bishop the bishop will
defend the pawn so now this
you know sacrificing the queen isn't
going to be a good idea for white
we'll see rook a to a1
rook to g8 trying to see if it can do
anything
on this semi-open file the bishop's
blocking it right now
rook a to g1 and now white may be
looking at
capturing on g5 in the future as another
sacrifice
rook to g6 this rook lift is very
important as it will help
protect the h6 pawn the knight will come
to f4
looking to trade itself off for some of
black's pieces
white is trying to trade off this knight
that while good in the center isn't
really contributing to the attack
it might benefit white to be able to
trade it off for some of the pieces
black is using to defend with
after knight to f4 we will see the
bishop take
the queen will take on f4 the queen will
come to f6
and we see this little tactical exchange
here white
takes on g6 allowing the queen to hang
queen takes queen white is currently
downey queen
for a rook but after rook h to h6
black is forced to recapture with the
queen
because otherwise black is just mated
there's nowhere to move the king
once the queen takes then the rook will
take back
king comes to g7 uh i guess the most
popular move or the book
move someone call it would be rook to h5
it's just staring at the a5 pawn and now
after bishop takes c4 pawn takes c4
this position has been worked out to be
an even end game
for both sides so earlier we had people
talking about how
you know it's all theory until it's a
draw this is one of those lines
where it has been worked out to this
equal equal end game yes
book moves in the end game memento
so that is the king d2 line and after
years of this line being played players
have decided that instead of king d2
they might score better chances with
king to f1
trying to speed up this attack leave the
second rank
open for their rook that way they don't
need to spend another tempo
say moving it to the back rank or
needing to maneuver the queen around to
bring the rook in on the first
it's like the berlin end game but three
times longer says manny
here we will see black play pawn to f5
so this is the big break black has been
trying to play
this entire time they've been preparing
f5 and now they got it
after pawn to f5 uh you'll again see
white
ignore this threat on the e pawn and
just bring the rook to a2
getting ready to swing it over to h2
f takes e4 doing a couple things for
black one is winning a pawn right off
the bat and two
it's opening up this file for the rook
so it's not like white is just getting
this
crazy crushing attack from nothing black
does have this counter play
that white needs to be mindful of
luckily for white their attack comes a
little bit sooner they swing the rook
over to h2
and you will see black play pawn to g5
again protecting this
bishop this is a theme that we have been
seeing in the other lines
and now um that this pawn is no longer
on g6
this allows the queen to come all the
way to h5
join in on this attack on the on the h
file here
and just again keep putting more and
more pressure on black's
king i never said this was going to be
an easy opening for black
here the main move has been rook to b7
there is a couple other alternatives
here mainly knight to e5 i think knight
to e5
is a alternative here of course white
cannot take this knight
because of the pin so to make this a
real threat
white moves the king to e2 after king to
e2
black has a couple different options
here probably one of the least
successful is going to be bishop to g4
check
this forces the knight to recapture as
it is a fork between the king and queen
after the knight captures on g4 the
other knight captures on c4 bc4
and queen c8 will put some more pressure
on white's position
hitting the knight and the pawn the
knight on the g
file will come over to e3 to protect c4
the queen will move to d7 possibly
trying to come in on the a file
queen to h6 and rook to f7 to defend
on the seventh rank this position is
about
plus one and a half depending on how
long you let your your computer think it
could be more could be less
but again this is not theoretically the
best line
for black the bishop to g4
another try from black in this position
another line for black in this position
is um
knight takes c4 right away after knight
takes c4
instead of capturing back on c4 it would
be very very tempting to take on c4
right away
you'll actually see black capture or
sorry white capture on
g5 first trying to
weaken this h file more really really
trying to
mate black rook takes b3
just trying to get the pawn you're also
wanting to make sure this knight isn't
going to be attacked by a pawn
and then also trying to get access to
the second rank
you may see black try to get on the
second rank and trade for the rook on h2
to try and trade off kind of a passive
piece
for an attacker one of the better ways
to stave off an
attack but here just rook takes h4 and
white is going to have massive pressure
on the h file you'll see like rook to b2
to check the king
but the knight can make its way to c2
give itself up
if the rook takes then king to d1
surprisingly sacrificing the knight and
there really is no good way
to stop this queen coming to h7 you'll
see the knight come to e3 and check
but the knight can take and after the
queen makes its way to the seventh rank
just knight takes c2 and white is just
going to be
up a rook
so knight e5 has been played those lines
typically don't look so great for black
so black goes for rook b7 just
immediately defending h7
and over the course of the rest of these
moves you'll see
both rooks and the queen make their way
to the seventh rank to defend
this this pawn over here
king to e2 by white the main idea is
just breaking this pin
uh it would be rather unfortunate if
this file rips open and bla
yeah black starts checking white starts
attacking uh the other way around
because you'll notice white's pieces
aren't really doing a whole great job of
protecting the queen side
most of the pieces at least all the
heavies are focused
towards the king side
you'll see black play bishop to e6
trying to develop this bishop
again trying to trade itself off for
some of white's good pieces
is also kind of making white not want to
move this night because then a capture
on c4
can ruin some of the pawn structure
if the knight recaptured then it would
hang the b3 pawn to the rook
and here you will see the move queen h6
by
white so there's a couple reasons why
this might be
one of them is to just put pressure on
the rook right away it makes it a lot
harder
for black just to bring the queen up and
defend for example
if they do it right away then just queen
f8 is going to be
mate real quick like bishop g4 and
knight e7 will
will help the mate
so here bishop to g8 bringing in another
defender to the h7 pawn
uh and here again a couple other moves
instead of bishop g8 one of the more
interesting ones maybe just bishop takes
right away but
after knight takes rook f to f7 to
defend the seventh rank
and queen e6 at first the engine is all
over the place it doesn't know how to
evaluate this position but i believe
this was seen in a correspondence game
and it saw white wind due to the
pressure
so bishop g8 is protecting the h7
pawn and now you'll see white kind of
give up control of this h file
they still have it secured but they also
start focusing on other points in
black's position
the move here is rook to g2
getting ready to put more pressure on
the g
file over here
you'll see bishop takes d5 knight takes
d5
and knight to e7 again black is just
trying to trade off these attackers
with this rook no longer on h2 there
aren't any ideas of sacrificing on
h4 so it's going to be harder for white
to break open the h file
that's why black is able to get away
with removing a defender off of this h7
pawn
in case anybody was wondering
rook takes g5 is a example of a
sacrifice this bishop cannot take
because of checkmate
so this pawn is hanging here you will
see black play knight takes d5
and rook takes d5 just moving the rook
out of danger
because now that this knight is off of
e7
this rook all the way over on b7 is
protecting the mate threat so you do
have to move this rook it is under
attack
you just move it to recapture the piece
and it is safe
here the only move where black does not
lose
right away is bishop to f6 if you are
playing this as black
bishop to f6 is a must
you will see white play rook d2h5 again
putting more pressure
on the h7 square this is a constant
target for white
and what black is constantly trying to
defend
the best move here is queen to e7 so the
queen joins in the defense
the rook cannot come up to f7 because of
the bishop
and this is just giving away free
material so queen has to come up to
defend
why doesn't rook h4 work asks max
emiliano on which
move let's see
um probably after knight takes d5
i think after knight takes d5 people are
wondering why rook takes doesn't work
and this is because knight takes on c3
with
check and black will start getting some
counter play in the position let's say
the king goes
king goes f1 so it can't be checked by
the knight pawn to d5
is going to start getting these center
pawns rolling cut the bishop
out of the attack and again currently
the rook
does control the mating square so
hopefully that answered maximiliano's
question
we'll recapture here on d5 with the rook
bishop to f6
rook swings over to the h file queen e7
to protect
h7 and here white is really just trying
to find every resource they can to break
through
and you'll see the move queen to g6
at first it looks like you're hanging
the queen but this pawn
is pinned and you will see
black um play a queen to g7 an
alternative maybe
just bishop takes on c3 but i i'm not
sure
the the theoretical value of this move
queen to g7 has been the theoretical
main line
after queen to g7 queen takes e4
getting the pawn and it might look like
you're just giving away material
um there's a move here that black has
that looks like it's winning
but there is a way out of it so i'm
going to give the chat just a little bit
of time see if they can find
this what looks to be a tactic and what
white's response to get out of it is
have any suggestions
what does black play here and white's
best response
someone is suggesting rook to e8
unfortunately rook to e8 just
loses the game in spectacular fashion
after queen takes e8
and now the queen has to block and after
the queen blocks
queen takes g8 is mate so uh
no rook e8 is not the move
rook e7 yes rook e7 is popping up in the
chat and rook e7
does look like it's going to win
material if the bishop just takes e7
then the queen can take and white is
going to be down the queen for a rook
which is not going to be pleasant there
is um
two moves that white has here to get out
of this
so we'll see uh see what people are
suggesting how does white
get out of this sticky situation with
this pin on the queen
rook g7 check is not legal
we have some people suggesting bishop to
e6
and we have some other people suggesting
rook to h7
both of these moves are playable both of
them do solve this
issue for white probably the the sharper
line is going to be uh
rook takes h7 this is uh what
what i've looked at this is what i play
but bishop e6
is also playable if the other rook comes
behind to try and pile up on the bishop
then you can move the king out of the
way and actually let this
bishop go because after rook h7
if queen h7 then queen is mate and if
the king moves down
then rook takes g7 with check and the
queen has time to escape
with queen to h7
so again both moves are playable
um but i'm going to go ahead with rook
takes h7 here
queen takes h7 is practically forced it
was a fork between the king and the
queen
here you will see the rook recapture and
here
rook has to recapture because this g8
square don't forget
is blocked by the c4 bishop
rook takes h7 and here now you'll see
the queen move to e3
just kind of getting control of some of
the dark squares
in the position looking maybe to come
over to the g
file in the future and again this
rook e7 idea is just shut down with
bishop to e6
if the rook comes over this time without
the rooks to help with the attack you
have to play f5
to secure the bishop and here you're
going to wind up in an
end game where it is a queen and pawn
for two rooks
which materialistically is equal but
some may say that the position is better
for white because
black's king is not active and nothing
is attacking white's king
so queen to e3 i should also mention
queen to e3 is also protecting the c3
pawn from the bishop on f6
rook to c8 trying to put some pressure
here trying to prevent this
bishop from moving queen to g3 like i
said the queen is just coming over to
the g file
and the last move is bishop to g7
i'm going to end the theory here we're
going to say that is
a lot of theory to go over we're going
to let that sink in for a couple minutes
and just enjoy what looks to be an even
end game um i will say the shreshnikov
is a very fun sharp opening for for both
sides
um i know i think giri said a few years
ago i think it was back in 2017
i think it might have been at tata steel
he said that with the shefeshnikov black
is struggling
to to maintain the attack to get to a
difficult end game that they need to
maintain
so as black i know someone earlier in
the chat was suggesting knight e7 lines
i haven't looked at any of the e7 lines
personally um
when i prepped my fashion akav work um
it was against the co-worker who plays
the shreshnikov and he plays these lines
that i showed tonight
but yeah if you are wanting to play as
black um those knight e7 lines are
probably going to be more useful
uh if you are white and trying to figure
out how to bust this freshnikov
this is definitely a very fun attacking
opening
this opening is one of my favorites to
play against in blitz it's always a good
wild time
i'm going to give a chat a couple
seconds to ask any questions that they
may have
if you have any questions about specific
moves please make sure to put in the
move number
we'll take a look at any alternatives
that people have questions about
we'll see if we can answer those in our
last 10 to 15 minutes
all right i'm not seeing many questions
how far do i know this opening in my
head
that's a very good question so i did
mention i did
prepare this stuff against an actual
opponent so this isn't like uh
i just came up with this for this class
this is stuff in my opening repertoire
um as far as the main line goes
um
i probably know like up to move king f1
so on move 22
and then um here i i really just have to
try and recall the plans i don't
remember many specific move orders
but i do know that king f1 and then you
bring the rook down to swing over
for a big attack
uh what if white goes for the plan of
short castling
uh on what move on what move would white
go for short castling
um
let's see when is short castling even
first available so
you have to protect the pawn king h8 is
going for f5 so
you have to play knight to e3 to stop f5
pawn to g6 um so they're probably asking
about pawn to g6
what if white short castles here
definitely a very natural looking move
and it's not a horrible move it's not
like you're blundering anything
short castles is playable uh here in
this position the problem
uh not a problem it's like one of the
things you give up when you play short
castles
is just you you get rid of this very
sharp idea of
h4
um so that is what white gives up kind
of gives black
a little bit of freedom to move around
like black can instantly play f5 which
is the break they were wanting to play
before
uh and it's a little difficult to see
what what all white
should do uh i think computer is
recommending rook to e1
let me see if this is a book position
it is it looks like the most played move
is queen to d3 bishop to e6
and rook to d1 queen d7 f3
is the main line pawn to f4 and this
reminds me a lot of like a king's indian
defense type of structure over here on
the king side
night comes to c2 it looks like this
night
where is this night going actually
looks like it might be trying to come to
b5 maybe try and help pressure d6 but
uh me personally i'm a little unsure
but needless to say i i don't recommend
short castles
i do recommend h4
alright do we have any other questions
in the chat
paul kulikov is uh mentioning that there
are some positions where white will take
on
f6 so back whenever the bishop is on f6
um that white will take and give black
double death pawns
um it that is possible
um those can also be double-edged
because uh like i mentioned earlier i
think i gave one of these lines
where um yeah the pawn recaptures and
then uh
white tries and goes for a fianchetto
set up
i think here in this line they're not
though but like you just have to be
careful black is going to get this rook
to g8
manny just to answer your question
thanks for the compliments this is not
my first lecture
however this is my first lecture in
quite a while
probably about a year i used to teach a
lot on stream about a year ago
and then once the classes moved
completely online
i kind of took a step back focused more
on giving private lessons
instead of the classes but again the
compliments are
are very nice thank you
looks like yaroslav is saying they tried
to play this position as black engine
keeps saying it was plus one
and the games didn't go so well um yeah
so i don't play this as black um
yes um the engine does give white
favorable evaluations in most lines i
feel if you were trying to um
go for the most equal line um
you probably have to hope white plays c4
and after they play c4 kind of go into
more of a positional type
game where white's going to trap in
their light square bishop
this would be ideal if they play um
c4 c3
you're probably going to have to play oh
where'd that line go
i don't know probably hope they play
king d2 again like i was saying um
geary in 2017 was uh saying that you
know this position is very difficult for
black to get to a very difficult end
game for black
so definitely not my top recommendation
but it is very good at the club level
very fun very sharp play by both sides
so hopefully this was a good intro to
the sreshnikov
for everybody
again thank you all for the compliments
i think i am going to wrap it up here
with a couple minutes to spare at the
end going to take a short break and then
we're going to come back
with tactics time we're going to talk
about how computers
just don't know anything about chess
we're going to have some
nice puzzles that computers can't solve
and i'll see you guys there
thank you for stopping in have a good
night
[Music]
you